welcome to the neural network tutorial
my name is richard kirschner i'm with
the simply learn team what's in it for
you well today we're going to cover what
is a neural network what can neural
networks do how does a neural network
work
types of neural networks and then we're
going to jump into a use case to
classify between the photos of dogs and
cats and we'll do that on the cross with
the tensorflow in the back but it's a
python script so that's always my
favorite part is when we dive into the
actual script
so what is a neural network so hi guys i
heard you want to know what a neural
network is here we have uh looks like
you just went shopping at a red tag cell
my robot's back so as a matter of fact
you have been using neural network on a
daily basis and today's world is just
amazing how much we use our new
technology we're not even aware of it
when you ask your mobile assistant to
perform a search for you like saying
your google or siri or whoever you use
amazon web self-driving cars so that's
the newest thing coming out they're just
now trying to make those legal and
different states in the u.s and around
the world even in the uk they now have a
self-driving cars going up and down the
streets pretty amazing these are all
neural network driven computer games use
it a lot of computer games are driven by
neural networks in the back end as part
of the game system and how it adjusts to
the players and it's also used in
processing the map images on your phone
so every time you do a navigation
someplace and it opens it up they now
use neural networks to help you find the
quickest way to get there neural network
a neural network is a system or hardware
that is designed to operate like a human
brain in today's development this is so
important to understand because we don't
have anything else to compare it to i'm
sure someday in the future the computer
will redefine or the neural network or
the ai artificial intelligence will
redefine what these mean but as far as
we can today's world in today's
commercial development we have to
compare it to what humans do so as we
want to compare and how it operates to a
human brain and how it solves problems
like a human does what can a neural
network do and really we're just going
to dive in deeper to what we just
covered and look at other examples so
what can a neural network do well let's
list out the things neural networks can
do for you translate text boy we got
google translate and microsoft has their
own translate they have some really cool
they actually have an earpiece it's
supposed to start translating as you
talk what a cool technology what a cool
time to live identify faces can you
imagine all the uses for facial
identification in the case of our
sample or our code that we're going to
look at later we'll be identifying dogs
and cats so not quite as detailed as
understanding whose face belongs to who
i'm waiting for the google glasses to
come out so i can see who's who and
identify faces as i'm walking around
have a little name tag over them not out
there yet but boy we are close we can
identify the faces and they have all
kinds of technologies to bring that
information back to us recognize speech
goes along with the translate text so
now as you're talking into your
assistant it can use that to do commands
turn lights on all kinds of things you
can do with recognizing speech read had
written text they're starting to
translate all these old text documents
that they've had in storage instead of
doing it individually where somebody's
going through each text by themselves in
a room picture like an old raiders of
the lost ark theme where he's in the
back you know archaeologists studying
the text now it's fed into a computer
they take a picture they even use neural
networks to take a scroll that is so
messed up that they can't undo the
scroll and they x-ray it and then they
use that x-ray to translate the text off
of it without ever opening the scroll i
mean just way cool stuff they're
starting to do with all this and of
course control robots what would be a
neural network without bringing in the
robots and we have our own favorite
robot in the middle who goes to our red
tag cell and go shopping for us so you
know these are just a few of the
wonderful things that neural networks
are being applied to it's such an infant
stage technology what a wonderful time
to jump in and there are a lot of other
things it goes into i mean we could
spend just forever talking about all the
different applications from business to
whatever you can even imagine they're
now applying neural networks to help us
understand
so now we talked a little bit about all
the cool things you can do with the
neural network let's dive in and say how
does a neural network work so now we've
come far enough to understand how neural
network works let's go ahead and walk
through this a nice graphical
representation they usually describe a
neural network as having different
layers you'll see that we've identified
a green layer an orange layer and a red
layer the green layer is the input so
you have your data coming in it picks up
the input signals and passes them to the
next layer the next layer does all kinds
of calculations and feature extraction
it's called the hidden layer a lot of
times there's more than one hidden layer
we're only showing one in this picture
but we'll show you how it looks like in
a more detail a little bit and then
finally we have an output layer this
layer delivers the final result so the
only two things we see is the input
layer and the output layer now let's
make use of this neural network and see
how it works wonder how traffic cameras
identify vehicles registration plate on
the road to detect speeding vehicles and
those breaking the law they got me going
through a red light the other day well
last month that's like the horrible
thing they send you this picture of you
and all your information because they
pulled it up off of your license plate
and your picture that shouldn't have
gone through the red light so here we
are and we have an image of a car you
can see the license plates on there so
let's consider the image of this vehicle
and find out what's on the number plate
the picture itself is 28 by 28 pixels
and the image is fed as an input to
identify the registration plate each
neuron has a number called activation
that represents the grayscale value of
the corresponding pixel range and we
range it from 0 to one one for a white
pixel and zero for a black pixel and you
can see down here we have an example
where one of the pixels is registered as
like 0.82 meaning it's probably pretty
dark each neuron is lit up when its
activation is close to one so as we get
closer to black on white we can really
start seeing the details in there and
you can see again the pixel shows this
one up there it's like part of the car
and so it lights up so pixels in the
form of arrays are fed to the input
layer and so we see here the pixel of a
car image fed as an input and you're
going to see that the input layer which
is green is one dimension while our
image is two dimension now when we look
at our setup that we're programming in
python it has a cool feature that
automatically does the work for us if
you're working with an older neural
network pattern package you then convert
each one of those rows so it's all one
array so you'd have like row one and
then just tack row two on to the end you
can almost feed the image directly into
some of these neural networks the key is
though is that if you're using a 28 by
28 and you get a picture of this 30 by
30 shrink the 30 by 30 down to fit the
28 by 28 so you can't increase the
number of input in this case green dots
it's very important to remember when you
work on neural networks and let's name
the inputs x1 x2 x3 respectively so each
one of those represents one of the
pixels coming in and the input layer
passes it to the hidden layer and you
can see here we now have two hidden
layers in this image in the orange and
each one of those pixels connects to
each one of those hidden layers and the
interconnections are assigned weights at
random so they get these random weights
that come through that if x1 lights up
then it's going to be x1 times this
weight going into the hidden layer and
we sum those weights the weights are
multiplied with the input signal and a
bias is added to all of them so as you
can see here we have x1 comes in and it
actually goes to all the different
hidden layer nodes or in this case
whatever you want to call them network
setup the orange dots and so you take
the value of x1 you multiply it by the
weight for the next hidden layer so x1
goes to hidden layer one x1 goes to
hidden layer two x1 goes hidden layer
one node two hidden layer one node three
and so on and the bias a lot of times
they just put the bias in as like
another green dot or another orange dot
and they give the bias a value one and
then all the weights go in from the bias
into the next node so the bias can
change we always just remember that you
need to have that bias in there there's
things that can be done with it
generally most the packages out there
control that for you so you don't have
to worry about figuring out what the
bias is but if you ever dive deep into
neural networks you've got to remember
there's a bias or the answer won't come
out correctly the weighted sum of the
input is fed as an input to the
activation function to decide which
nodes to fire and for feature extraction
as the signal flows within the hidden
layers the weighted sum of inputs is
calculated and is fed to the activation
function in each layer to decide which
nodes to fire so here's our feature
extraction of the number plate and you
can see these are still hidden nodes in
the middle and this becomes important
we're going to take a little detour here
and look at the activation function so
we're going to dive just a little bit
into the math so you can start to
understand where some of the games go on
when you're playing with neural networks
in your programming so let's look at the
different activation functions before we
move ahead here's our friendly red tag
shopping robot and so one is a sigmoid
function and the sigmoid function which
is 1 over 1 plus e to the minus x takes
the x value and you can see where it
generates almost a 0 and almost a 1 with
a very small area in the middle where it
crosses over and we can use that value
to feed into another function so if it's
really uncertain it might have a 0.1 or
0.2 or 0.3 but for the most part it's
going to be really close to 1 and really
close to this case 0 zero to one the
threshold function so if you don't wanna
worry about the uncertainty in the
middle you just say oh if x is greater
than or equal to zero if not then x is
zero so it's either zero or one really
straightforward there's no in between in
the middle and then you have the what
they call the relu relu function and you
can see here where it puts out the value
but then it says well if it's over one
it's going to be one and if it's less
than zero at zero so it kind of just
dead ends it on those two ends but
allows all the values in the middle and
again this like the sigmoid function
allows that information to go to the
next level so it might be important to
know if it's a 0.1 or a minus 0.1 the
next hidden layer might pick that up and
say oh this piece of information is
uncertain or this value has a very low
certainty to it and then the hyperbolic
tangent function and you can see here
it's a 1 minus e to the minus 2x over 1
plus e to the minus 2x and it's very
much along the same theme a little bit
different in here in that it goes
between minus one and one so you'll see
some of these they go zero to one but
this one goes minus one to one and if
it's less than zero it's you know it
doesn't fire and if it's over zero it
fires and it also still puts out a value
so you still have a value you can get
off of that just like you can with the
sigmoid function and the relu function
very similar in use and i believe the
original used to be everything was done
in the sigmoid function that was the
most commonly used and now they just
kind of use more the relu function the
reason is one it processes faster
because you already have the value and
you don't have to add another compute
the one over one plus e to the minus x
for each hidden node and the data coming
off works pretty good as far as putting
it into the next level if you want to
know just how close it is to zero how
close is it not to functioning you know
is it minus 0.1 minus 0.2 usually
they're float values you get like minus
point minus 0.00138 or something so you
know important information but the relu
is most commonly used these days as far
as the setup we're using but you'll also
see the sigmoid function very commonly
used also now that you know what an
activation function is let's get back to
the neural network so finally the model
would predict the outcome of applying a
suitable activation function to the
output layer so we go in here we look at
this we have the optical character
recognition ocr is used on the images to
convert it into a text in order to
identify what's written on the plate and
as it comes out you'll see the red note
and the red note might actually
represent just a letter a so there's
usually a lot of outputs when you're
doing text identification we're not
going to show that on here but you might
have it even in the order might be what
order the license plates in so you might
have a b c d e f g
you know the alphabet plus the numbers
and you might have the one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
places so it's a very large array that
comes out it's not a small amount of you
know we show three dots coming in eight
hidden layer nodes you know two sets of
four we just saw one red coming out a
lot of times this is uh you know 28
times 28 if you did 30 times 30 that's
you know 900 nodes so 28 is a little bit
less than that just on the input and so
you can imagine the hidden layer is just
as big each hidden layer is just as big
if not bigger and the output is going to
be there's so many digits yeah it's a
lot there's it's a huge amount of input
and output but we're only showing you
just you know it would be hard to show
in one picture and so it comes up and
this is what it finally gets out on the
output as it identifies a number on the
plate and in this case we have zero
eight dash d
zero three eight five eight error in the
output is back propagated through the
network and weights are adjusted to
minimize the error rate this is
calculated by a cost function when we're
training our data this is what's used
and we'll look at that in the code when
we do the data training so we have stuff
we know the answer to and then we put
the information through and it says yes
that was correct or no because remember
we randomly set all the weights to begin
with and if it's wrong we take that
error how far off are you are you off
but is it if it was like minus one
you're just a little bit off if it's
like minus 300 was your output remember
when we're looking at those different
options you know hyperbolic or whatever
and we're looking at the rel the rel
doesn't have a limit on top or bottom it
actually just generates a number so if
it's way off you have to adjust those
weights a lot but if it's pretty close
you might adjust the weights just a
little bit and you keep adjusting the
weights until they fit all the different
training models you put in so you might
have 500 training models and those
weights will adjust
using the back propagation it sends the
error backward the output is compared
with the original result and multiple
iterations are done to get the maximum
accuracy so not only does it look at
each one but it goes through it and just
keeps cycling through these the data
making small changes in the network
until it gets the right answers with
every iteration the weights at every
interconnection are adjusted based on
the error we're not going to dive into
that math because it is a differential
equation and it gets a little
complicated but i will talk a little bit
about some of the different options they
have when we look at the code so we've
explored a neural network let's look at
the different types of artificial neural
networks and this is like the biggest
area growing is how these all come
together let's see the different types
of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain i feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it a a n a neural
network data travels only in one
direction input to output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into big data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them used this form
of neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the sesame street as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get to where the drone
wants to go applications text-to-speech
conversation model so i talked about
drones but you know just identifying on
lexus or google assistant or any of
these they're starting to add in i'd
like to play a song on my pandora and
i'd like it to be at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so they
can do a face recognition on each person
applications used in signal and image
processing in this case i use facial
images or google picture images as one
of the options modular neural network it
has a collection of different neural
networks working together to get the
output so wow we just went through all
these different types of neural networks
and the final one is to put multiple
neural networks together i mentioned
that a little bit when we separated
people in a larger photo in individuals
in the photo and then do the facial
recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are into the facial recognition
applications still undergoing research
this is a cutting edge you hear the term
pipeline and there's actual in python
code and in almost all the different
neural network setups out there they now
have a pipeline feature usually and it
just means you take the data from one
neural network and maybe another neural
network or you put it into the next
neural network and then you take three
or four other neural networks and feed
them into another one so how we connect
the neural networks is really just
cutting edge and it's so experimental i
mean it's almost creative in its nature
there's not really a science to it
because each specific domain has
different things it's looking at so if
you're in the banking domain it's going
to be different than the medical domain
then the automatic car domain and
suddenly figuring out how those all fit
together is just a lot of fun and really
cool so we have our types of artificial
neural network we have our feed forward
neural network we have a radial basis
function neural network we have our
cohenon self-organizing neural network
recurrent neural network convolution
neural network and modular neural
network where it brings them all
together and no the colors on the brain
do not match what your brain actually
does but they do bring it out that most
of these were developed by understanding
how humans learn and as we understand
more and more of how humans learn we can
build something in the computer industry
to mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
a dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python 3.6 it's always nice
to tell people the version of python
because it does affect sometimes which
modules you load and everything and
we're going to start by importing the
required packages i told you we're going
to do this in karas so we're going to
import from karas models sequential from
the cross layers conversion 2d or conv
2d max pooling 2d flatten and dense and
we'll talk about what each one of these
do in just a second but before we do
that let's talk a little bit about the
environment we're going to work in and
you know in fact let me go ahead and
open a
the website cross's website so we can
learn a little bit more about karas so
here we are on the karass website and
it's a k-e-r-a-s dot io that's the
official website for karass and the
first thing you'll notice is that cross
runs on top of either tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or theano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the cross and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like cross and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now it's such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit they talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we're
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size
there we go that's big i can add in an r
e l u layer and then i can add in a soft
max layer the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you could do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one set up and then i feed
the output into the next one this one i
can just add hidden layer after hidden
layer with the different information in
it which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python 3 6
because i'm in python 36. anaconda's
cool that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing as you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit-learn
pillow and h5py are both needed for the
tensorflow and then putting the cross on
there and then you'll see here and pip
is just a standard installer that you
use with python you'll see here that we
did pip install tensorflow sensor we're
going to do cross on top of tensorflow
and then pip install and i went ahead
and used the github so git plus git and
you'll see here github.com this is one
of their releases one the most current
release on there that goes on top of
tensorflow and you can look up these
instructions pretty much anywhere this
is for doing it on anaconda certainly
you'd want to install these if you're
doing it in ubuntu server setup you'd
want to get i don't think you need the
h5py and ubuntu but you do need the rest
in there because there are dependencies
in there and it's pretty straightforward
and that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to initially go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can see i have
python 30.5 and python 36. i used to
have a bunch of other ones but it kind
of cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupiter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my
in this case i'm using google chrome and
in here i can go and just create a new
document in here and this is all in your
browser window when you use the anaconda
do you have to use anaconda and jupyter
notebook no you can use any kind of
python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential it's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this is just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you'll notice i'm always sipping coffee
i always have a in my case latte next to
me an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're just picking
specific objects your specific it's a
true or false yes no it is something or
it's not so first thing we're going to
create our classifier and it's going to
equal sequential so their sequential
setup is the classifier that's the
actual model we're using that's the
neural network so we call it a
classifier and the next step is to add
in our convolution and let me just do a
let me shrink that down in size you can
see the whole line and let's talk a
little bit about what's going on here i
have my classifier and i add something
what am i adding well i'm adding my
first layer this first layer we're
adding in is probably the one that takes
the most work to make sure you have it
set correct and the reason i say that
this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
picture's coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's the value coming out based
on the weights and the value going in
and
from there you know it's uh if it's over
one then it's good or over zero it's
good if it's under 0 then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple things it's doing in here a
little bit more in depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to
two-dimensional kind of setup so it's
very aware that this is a photograph and
that different pieces are next to each
other and then we're going to add in a
second convolutional layer that's what
the conv stands for 2d so it's these are
hidden layers so we have our input layer
and our two hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing what
the two-dimensional photograph and
you'll see down here that on the last
one we add a max pooling 2d and we put a
pool size equals 2 2. and so what this
is is that as you get to the end of
these layers one of the things you
always want to think of is what they
call mapping and then reducing wonderful
terminology from the big data we're
mapping this data through all these
layers and now we want to reduce it to
only two sets in this case it's already
in two sets because the 2d photograph
but we had you know two dimensions by we
actually have 64 by 64 by three so now
we're just getting it down to a two by
two just the two dimension two
dimensional instead of having the third
dimension of colors and we'll go ahead
and run these we're not really seeing
anything in our run script because we're
just setting up this is all set up and
this is where you start playing because
maybe you'll add a different layer in
here to do something else to see how it
works and see what your output is that's
what makes cross so nice is i can with
just a couple flips of code put in a
whole new layer that does a whole new
processing and see whether that improves
my run or makes it worse and finally
we're going to do the final setup which
is to flatten classifier add a flatten
setup and then we're going to also add a
layer a dense layer and then we're going
to add in another dense layer and then
we're going to build it we're going to
compile this whole thing together so
let's flip over and see what that looks
like and we've even numbered them for
you so we're going to do the flattening
and flatten is exactly what it sounds
like we've been working in a
two-dimensional array of picture which
actually is in three dimensions because
of the pixels the pixels have a whole
other dimension to it of three different
values and we've kind of resized those
down to two by two but now we're just
going to flatten it i don't want to have
multiple dimensions being worked on by
tensor and by keras i want just a single
array so it's flattened out and then
step four full connection so we add in
our final two layers and you could
actually do all kinds of things with
this you could actually leave out this
some of these layers and play with them
you do need to flatten it that's very
important then we want to use the dents
again we're taking this and we're taking
whatever came into it so once we take
all those different the two dimensions
or three dimensions as they are and we
flatten it to one dimension we want to
take that and we're going to pull it
into units of 128 they got that you just
say where did they get 128 from you
could actually play with that number and
get all kinds of weird results but in
this case we took the 64 plus 64 as 128.
you could probably even do this with 64
or 32. usually you want to keep it in
the same multiple whatever the data
shape you're already using is in and
we're using the activation the relu just
like we did before and then we finally
filter all that into a single output and
it has how many units one why because we
want to know whether true or false it's
either a dog or a cat you could say one
is dog zero is cat or maybe you're a cat
lover and it's one is cat and zero is
dog if you love both dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid the sigmoid
just makes it clear it's yes or no we
don't want any kind of in-between number
coming out and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it's still all in
setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does adam come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might blur that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up to even know
what that is there's so many of these a
lot of times you just start with the
ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
with these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the cross website to explore them deeper
but we are going to go ahead and run
them and now we've set up our classifier
so we have an object classifier and if
you go back up here you'll see that
we've added in step one we added in our
layer for the input we added a layer
that comes in there and uses the relu
for activation and then it pulls the
data so this is even though these are
two layers the actual neural network
layer is up here and then it uses this
to pull the data into a two by two so
into a two-dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our outer
flatten and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces it so you can look at
this as we're mapping all this data down
the two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128 and we use the relu again
and then finally we reduce that down to
just a single output and we use the
sigmoid to do that to figure out whether
it's yes no true false in this case cat
or dog and then finally once we put all
these layers together we compile them
that's what we've done here and we've
compiled them as far as how it trains to
use these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it or you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neural network to
the images and then from cross let me
just zoom in there i always love that
about working with jupiter notebooks you
can really see we're going to come in
here we do the cross pre-processing an
image and we import image data generator
so nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gen and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it'll generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code and this
one is just huge we're creating the
training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know see colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the classes
we're switching everything to a binary
value batch size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64. a
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using 20 percent of the images as tests
and 80 to train it and then finally
we've set up all our data we've set up
all our layers which is where all the
work is is cleaning up that data and
making sure it's going in there
correctly and we're actually going to
fit it we're going to train our data set
and let's see what that looks like and
here we go let's put the information in
here and let's just take a quick look at
what we're looking at with our fit
generator we have our classifier dot fit
generator that's our back propagation so
the information goes through forward
with a picture and it says up you're
either right or you're wrong and then
the air goes backward and reprograms all
those weights so we're training our
neural network and of course we're using
the training set remember we created the
training set up here and then we're
going steps per epic so it's 8 000 steps
epic means that that's how many times we
go through all the pictures so we're
going to rerun each of the pictures and
we're going to go through the whole data
set 25 times but we're going to look at
each picture during each epic 8 000
times so we're really programming the
heck out of this and going back over it
and then they have validation data
equals test set so we have our training
set and then we're gonna have our test
set to validate it so we're gonna do
this all in one shot and we're gonna
look at that and they're gonna do 200
steps for each validation and we'll see
what that looks like in just a minute
let's go ahead and run our training here
and we're going to fit our data and as
it goes it says epic one of 25 you start
realizing that this is going to take a
while on my older computer it takes
about 45 minutes i have a dual processor
and we're processing uh 10 000 photos
that's not a small amount of photographs
to process so if you're on your laptop
in which i am it's going to take a while
so let's go ahead and go get our cup of
coffee and a sip and come back and see
what this looks like so i'm back you
didn't know i was gone that was actually
a lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i change these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic 10 epics and just 10
validation steps and this will cause
problems if you're doing this as a
commercial release but for demo purposes
this should work and if you remember our
steps per epic that's how many photos
we're going to process in fact let me go
ahead and get my drawing pin out and
let's just highlight that right here
well we have 8 000 pictures we're going
through so for each epic i'm going to
change this to i'm going to cut that in
half so it's going to randomly pick 4
000 pictures each time it goes through
an epic and the epic is how many
processes so this is 25 and i'm just
going to cut that to 10. so instead of
doing 25 runs through 8 000 photos each
which you can do the math of twenty five
times eight thousand i'm only going to
do ten through four thousand so i'm
going to run this forty thousand times
through the processes and the next thing
i notice you'll you'll wanna notice is
that i also change the validation step
and this would cause some major problems
in releasing because i dropped it all
the way down to 10. what the validation
step does is it says we have 2 000
photos in our trainings are in our
testing set and we're going to use that
for validation well i'm only going to
use a random 10 of those to validate so
not really the best settings but let me
show you why we did that let's scroll
down here just a little bit and let's
look at the output here and see what
that what's going on there so i've got
my drawing tool back on and you'll see
here it lists a run so each time it goes
through an epic it's going to do 4 000
steps and this is where the 4 000 comes
in so that's what we have we have epic
one of 10 4 000 steps it's randomly
picking half the pictures in the file
and going through them and then we're
going to look at this number right here
that is for the whole epic and that's 2
411 seconds and if you remember
correctly you divide that by 60 you get
minutes if you divide that by 60 you get
hours or you can just divide the whole
thing by 60 times 60 which is 3600. if
3600 is an hour this is roughly 45
minutes right here and that's 45 minutes
to process half the pictures so if i was
doing all the pictures we're talking an
hour and a half per epic times 36 or no
25 they had 25 up above 25. so that's
roughly a couple days a couple days of
processing well for this demo we don't
want to do that i don't want to come
back the next day plus my computer did a
reboot in the middle of the night so we
look at this and we say okay let's we're
just testing this out my computer that
i'm running this on is a dual core
processor runs 0.9 gigahertz per second
for a laptop you know it's good about
four years ago but for running something
like this is probably a little slow so
we cut the times down and the last one
was validation we're only validating it
on a random 10 photos and this comes
into effect because you're going to see
down here where we have accuracy value
loss value accuracy and loss those are
very important numbers to look at so the
10 means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let's just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and you know
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy is
a very common package i pretty much
imported on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you know you can use a
standard data array from python and we
have cross pre-processing import image
fish that all look familiar because
we're going to take a test image and
we're going to set that equal to in this
case cat or dog one as you can see over
here and you know let me get my drawing
tool back on so let's take a look at
this we have our test image we're
loading and in here we have test image
one and this one hasn't data hasn't seen
this one at all so this is all new let
me shrink the screen down let me start
that over so here we have my test image
and we went ahead and the cross
processing has this nice image set up so
we're going to load the image and we're
going to alter it to a 64 by 64 print so
right off the bat we're going to cross
as nice that way it automatically sets
it up for us so we don't have to redo
all our images and find a way to reset
those and then we use also to set the
image to an array so again we're all in
pre-processing the data just like we
pre-processed before with our test
information and our training data and
then we use the numpy here's our numpy
that's uh from our right up here import
numpy as np expand the dimensions test
image axes equal zero so it puts it into
a single array and then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but according to
our software says it's a dog and uh we
have a second picture over here let's
just see what happens when we run the
second picture we can go up here and
change this uh from dog image one to two
we'll run that and it comes down here
and says cat you can see me highlighting
it down there as cat so our process
works you're able to label a dog a dog
and a cat a cat just from the pictures
there we go cleared my drawing tool and
the last thing i want you to notice when
we come back up here to when i ran it
you'll see that has an accuracy of 1 and
the value accuracy of 1. well the value
accuracy is the important one because
the value accuracy is what it actually
runs on the test data remember i'm only
testing it on i'm only validating it on
a random 10 photos and those 10 folders
just happen to come up one now when they
ran this on the server it actually came
up about 86 percent this is why cutting
these numbers down so far for a
commercial release is bad so you want to
make sure you're a little careful of
that when you're testing your stuff that
you change these numbers back when you
run it on a more enterprise computer
other than your old laptop that you're
just practicing on or messing with and
we come down here and again you know we
have the validation of cat and so we
have successfully built a neural network
that could distinguish between photos of
a cat and a dog imagine all the other
things you could distinguish imagine all
the different industries you could dive
into with that just being able to
understand those two difference of
pictures what about mosquitoes could you
find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
so key takeaways well we covered what is
a neural network we use all kinds of
processing the map images on your phone
we talked about things that a neural
network can do translate text identify
faces all the way to control robots you
know lots of exciting things how does a
neural network work so we discussed that
with the different layers going from the
picture to the input layer to the hidden
layers and their weights to the final
output layer we also talked about how it
does the math in computing the output as
yes or no categorically true false we
discussed types of artificial neural
networks a lot of vocabulary there from
the feed forward neural network which is
the most commonly used that's one the
neural network we used is a feed forward
neural network that does backward
propagation to train and there's a lot
of other ones out there there's the
radial biases the cohenon
self-organizing recurrent neural network
convolution neural network modular
neural network the big one was modular
because it incorporates pieces of all
the other ones so that whatever you're
working on now is a huge conglomerate of
multiple networks just all cutting edge
all of it's new people even working on
it don't even know where it's going
again very exciting times and finally we
dug through my favorite part you can see
with my latte on one side my old school
pins and pencil and all my sticky notes
working away that's not actually me by
the way
you probably guessed that and we walked
through and actually did a cat and dog
photo a simple cat and dog photo and you
could see where some of the problems are
in processing large amounts of
photographs and data where that starts
to become going from a single machine on
my laptop with this you know lower
amount of resources all the way to big
data however processing hundreds and
thousands of these photos this now needs
to be set up on an enterprise machine or
even on a cluster of computers again
significantly past the scope of this the
neat part about it though is once you
write this code mosta's code they now
have tools that you can almost take the
same ideas if not the actual code and
push it right on to a cluster
computation so really cool times for
this again thank you for joining us
today glad to have you i hope you
learned something new something exciting
for more information visit
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead if you have any
questions on the video you can certainly
go to our website and ask our support
team if you'd like a copy of a zip file
of the data we can send that to you you
can also post to questions on the
youtube video down below again thank you
for joining us today and i hope you have
a wonderful and happy learning journey
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here